the daily wire has been hard at work
keeping their promise of bringing you
tons of content that you won't get
anywhere else
we are very excited to share one of our
highly anticipated trailers with you
the trailer features our first original
production
we released a movie last year called run
hide fight but we didn't make that movie
we acquired that movie
when hollywood didn't want to distribute
it because it wasn't politically correct
but we didn't we didn't actually produce
it this one we produced it's called shut
in it'll be available to stream in early
2022.
the film follows the story of a young
mother who is barricaded inside a closet
by her violent ex-husband
i haven't even seen the trailer yet
here it is lainey
[Music]
[Applause]
where have you been
going away
i'm gonna take off tonight so the kids
can sleep most of the way
[Music]
well i'm mostly done i just need to
finish cleaning out the pantry
[Music]
thinking
through the night
[Music]
nope
[Music]
please let me out please
[Music]
your
lady
she's very pretty don't you touch my
kids
rob
owes me money there's money there's a
lot of money there's thousands of
dollars in the pantry have it all
please come on i'm scared
that looks good
[Applause]
that not that i'm saying i didn't think
it would be good i did know it would be
there's a lot of talent at the daily
wire but still when conservatives
have made movies sometimes look some
conservative movies have been terrific
uh and some have been a little
schmaltzy a little saccharine you know a
little
kitschy and sentimental
uh not that that
that no that that looks pretty pretty
real and gritty i can't wait to watch it
can't wait to watch the whole movie make
sure you go like and share the trailer
on youtube your support makes all the
difference